hey what's going on as bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna I'm just checking in on you I'm
just checking in on yes just seeing how
your weeks going you know during this
first month of a new year over the
decade and I hope you having a good time
I hope you out there and join yourself I
hope you're not on the internet watching
people yelling at each other
be they feminists who don't trim their
hoo-has or be they people with red ties
or people with blue ties that everybody
[ __ ] screaming and yelling at each
other actually it's a small portion
screaming and yelling and everybody else
is just sitting there watching I hope
you having a good week all right how's
that is this something positive for you
and your on the Internet in its it's
hopefully making you feel better as you
stare at the plastic grace screws that
hold the cubicle together it's something
uplifting I just got back from New
Orleans had a great time I went to the
championship game against the Tagus the
LSU Tigers against the Clemson Tigers
and went down there I you know came down
went down my parents Joe bartnik club
soda kenny and we just had the best time
ever hanging out there doing shows going
around the city you know I told you guys
red beans and rice I'm gonna figure out
how to make that [ __ ] some sort of you
know my I'm gonna take my attempt at
that anybody has a decent recipe that
you could part with and send my way I
would appreciate it
I absolutely loved it and we just had
the best time and went down to the game
we were all scam I was kind of teasing
the president why is he going to the
game
don't she have like the sickest flat
screen ever in the White House and but
it was really not that big a deal we
actually left for the game at like 4
o'clock started at 7 and we were there
and in our seats you know after the
traffic and all the [ __ ] by like I
don't know five five o'clock maybe 5 15
and we just sat there hanging out and it
was cool we got this so early like we
were watching both teams practicing
without their jerseys on and we watched
Joe Burrell just throw one after another
those sideline passes and Kenny was
joking like he should throw some to the
other side I'm like he's gonna you know
he's just being Kenny right so of course
he does all of that and then you know
we're watching the game and you watch
them in real time start completing those
passes
what a [ __ ] game man
I'll tell you in the beginning you know
I rent to this guy I think it was on
Royal Street Royal Street or whatever in
the French Quarter and he used to play
for clubs and he was just like Clemson's
gonna beat him I think they're gonna win
by like 14 I was thinking like [ __ ] I
know and everybody's saying LSU here's a
guy who played for Clemson you know
actually played the game as opposed to
listening to all these [ __ ] drunk
people who live here who are LSU fans
telling me LSU was gonna kill him and
all of this [ __ ] and then the game
starts and LSU was just pinned down in
there down in there their sight of the
feeling like that the punter I swear to
God if Clem's have won that game I swear
he should've got at least co-mvp I don't
know how many times he pinned the LSU
Tigers all the way down you know on the
3 4 5 yard line it just they just seemed
like the other first three possessions
were down there and I love that game
plan where they just were blitzing the
Clemson Tigers just kept blitzing and
when I was just like man if they don't
make them pay for this like this is
gonna this could be a problem and it
just really looked like it was going to
be Clemson stay there for a minute you
know I want to say they went up seven
and nothing at all just you know when
you go to the game it's hard to [ __ ]
you know all this [ __ ] that's going all
the crazy people in the crowd there's
this Clemson guy in front of me with big
mother and hips right this dude
stupid [ __ ] orange thing on and he
got mad in the beginning cuz this guy in
front of me was an LSU Tiger fan cheered
for something he yelled at him for Chi
ring and then they got in this big
argument or whatever
well Lilith shoe guy just called him out
for being a douche and then the guy like
five minutes a guy was my bad that was
my bad and then he made like a big
production about apologize you should
just say that was my bad I shouldn't
done it then he had to hug the guy and
then he came over and fist bump came
back and [ __ ] slap on the back like
every like heterosexual possible way
that another man could touch another man
he did it it was just like alright we
get it we get it you let your emotions
get the best you so that shit's going on
while you trying to watch the [ __ ]
game and not to mention was so [ __ ]
loud have you just going oh you know
when Clemson had the ball
I literally just was sitting there
blocking my ears I was like I don't give
a [ __ ] if I look like a [ __ ] or
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] my ears a
shot from playing drums I'm not you know
like the guys voices are bad enough but
when the women get going
he had that high pitch on top you know
forget about it so I want to say it was
like 17 to 7 and then Clemson came just
came roaring back and I was nervous I
thought burrows was running too much I'm
like why not [ __ ] they using their
running back and the last time I went
there for a championship game I saw the
New England Patriots beat the greatest
show on turf and Mike Martz didn't use
Marshall [ __ ] and I'm like what the [ __ ]
is building but anyways once they got
going holy [ __ ] but you know Clemson
came back right after the half and but
they could just never get close and III
don't know man that was just it was
something else
it was really something else and you
know I saw the Patriots win the Super
Bowl there and it wasn't as loud as that
like it was just [ __ ] craziness and
no fights just fans will fund Trump came
out on the field like right in front of
us you know place went crazy everybody
loving him people chanting four more
years and [ __ ] I'm just saying there was
some boobers but overall positive so I
was thinking like god this guy's going
to you know this guy's gonna hang you
know he did his little photo op it's
politics right
so I figured this guy's gonna do his
little [ __ ] photo op but he's gonna
be out of here but I think he stayed and
watched the game so I thought that was
that was cool other than you know just
getting out of the whole politics thing
about it but the security getting in
wasn't that bad there was Secret Service
people there but they they did it very
very very efficiently and I have to tell
you man that is the greatest dome that
has ever been made I have to say that
for when it was built for how it looks I
know they redid it and everything it's
just the best dome you know and the
newer ones with all the luxury box and
the fans are just so [ __ ] far away
this is like and this thing seemed like
when it was made it seemed like it was
the biggest thing ever and how far away
you were now that's like nothing if you
go to the Cowboys Stadium you know I
mean you could literally I don't give
anybody ideas I forget I'm not gonna say
that I was gonna use an example of what
you could you know if you [ __ ] I'm
not gonna say that if you were to take a
paper airplane so anyway my only thing
that I didn't like about the game was
the it was how long it took it was like
[ __ ] ridiculously said a guy come out
on the field and he had a clock so you
just sit down we we just stood the whole
game and you know the game should have
been three hours long they turn it into
like [ __ ] like was it a four hour and
over for our game man it was so [ __ ]
long and we got there extra early so I
mean I was basically there from five
o'clock in the afternoon to midnight and
got out of there but it was just it was
just such an awesome experience and but
that game is really becoming as long as
the Super Bowl if it isn't already
here's a quick question for and it was
great just seeing you know all those LSU
fans losing their minds Clemson fans
were all cool great fans just on both
sides uh it was just an awesome
experience but I I was thinking you know
because they have JLo and Shakira
jakirah for the halftime show if the
Super Bowl is Kansas City versus the San
Francisco 49ers my question is who does
more dancing
JLo and Shakira or the football players
on the [ __ ] the Chiefs and the 49ers
because I'm not say it all over but
there there's some [ __ ] people and
they celebrate every [ __ ] thing they
do everything they do there's some
defensive player who's [ __ ] amazing
he is amazing but Jesus Green you'd
think he was the first guy to ever get a
sack or tackle somebody I know I've said
this forever but it's somebody's got to
say it it's it's [ __ ] ridiculous
I love that guy Kelsey to one of the
best tight ends in the league you know
but it's just like he had like some
major [ __ ] drops in the beginning of
that game and then all of a sudden
starts catching balls
it was [ __ ] hilarious he caught this
ball and he's literally pushing the
defensive back off of him so he can get
up and start running around dance and
it's just like how come he didn't dance
when you drop the ball you know you seem
to like extra attention why don't you
keep the attention on you even during
the hard times then you could be an
inspiration so we could learn how to
overcome things all right so now that my
Super Bowl both of my Super Bowl pics
got blown out of the water
last week the Baltimore Ravens sent
packing by the Tennessee Titans and
sneaky pete in the seattle seahawks
those dirty birds up there how they got
[ __ ] you know they actually played a
great game it came on a little too late
they ran out of time there but by the
Green Bay Packers so now it's the
Packers versus the 49ers and what do we
got left we got the Titans Remember the
Titans against the Kansas City Chiefs
and you know I'm not gonna make any
predictions because I don't know [ __ ]
how about that and I don't
Jynx anybody because it seems like when
I [ __ ] watch people and I make
predictions like I I have a kid now I
lost my touch I used to be able to
predict things at a nice 18 percent clip
which is pretty good for a gambler which
is why you don't gamble so I have no
idea all I know is what's kind of great
is I don't have a dog in the fight so I
don't give a [ __ ] it's kind of a bunch
of feel-good games you know who's gonna
be mad if Kansas City goes who's [ __ ]
poor people have been waiting over 50
years who's gonna be mad at the Titans
go that's such a great underdog where
the hell did these guys come from then
as a Pats fan Mike Vrabel I got a root
for that guy I feel bad for Andy Rica's
ever he was it gives him [ __ ] you know
you know like everybody else has won a
[ __ ] Super Bowl who's giving him [ __ ]
you know and then the other side 49 is
you know great franchise great fans same
thing with the Packers I don't know no
no and I give a [ __ ]
yeah I'm just hoping for [ __ ] two
overtime games how about that and having
said that oh by the way what happened to
your houston astros Jesus Christ what a
scandal I cannot believe that a team
would take advantage of some sort of
technology to try and cheat you know
Jesus Christ they [ __ ] they went
after them you know it was [ __ ]
hilarious is my buddies who had Yankee
fans who were [ __ ] pissed and it's
just like Oh Mike and I was giving him
so much [ __ ] I was like yeah I can't
believe that they were stealing signs on
your roided-up players how quickly
people forget that your own team also
[ __ ] cheated it's like if they're
gonna if they're gonna take away the
Houston Astros title if Yankee fans and
I'm tell you something is it for you
[ __ ] Yankee fans if you [ __ ] say
that that's what should happen
alright know that you're gonna lose at
least three titles 99 2000 and 2009
alright if we're talking about cheating
you're gonna lose those all right I'm
not gonna say it cuz we had roided-up
players on our team to its
like come on grow a dick all right they
[ __ ] they did a little boss hogg [ __ ]
to you you know you shouldn't do it you
absolutely shouldn't do it but come on
man come on roids corked up bats pine
tar doctor in the ball I hate how you
can't do that anymore
I love the [ __ ] Phil Niekro and his
whatever this [ __ ] brothers they were
they had half their goddamn bathroom and
they have kitchen on that [ __ ]
baseball it was hilarious you looked at
their [ __ ] you looked at the front of
that Jersey they look like a trucker had
been driving for 14 hours hit like
mustard and [ __ ] every condiment you
can think of was just all over the front
of the [ __ ] shirt they had vaseline
on their pants he was [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] hilarious what are you gonna do
I I just I don't give a [ __ ]
haven't said that you shouldn't do [ __ ]
like that but like for people to really
get all up in arms about that stuff I
also like that somebody compared you
know Pete Rose get suspended for [ __ ]
life and all the Astros got was this
that and the other it's like okay anyway
gambling on baseball is way different
than cheating all right when you're the
manager of a [ __ ] team and you're
gambling on baseball and you're in that
[ __ ] position that starts making
people think that the whole thing's
fixed that is completely different than
one franchise getting busted for
cheating trying to win those are two I
think two different completely different
[ __ ] things I mean if somebody has a
corked bat should they be [ __ ] banned
for life because you're trying to cheat
as an individual gambling is a different
thing because when you gamble you don't
have any loyalty other than to money you
don't give a [ __ ] so now you know at
least the Astros the piece of [ __ ] thing
they were doing they were trying to win
so that makes sense where you get a
[ __ ] gambler the gambler I never bet
against my team but the end of the day
is a [ __ ] gambler
you know let's like going into a
jailhouse and listen to somebody they
were all [ __ ] innocent but whatever I
mean I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm not good
I think it's [ __ ] funny that they did
it I think it's funny that they did it
to a 200 million dollar team that has
done steroids in the past to help win
three [ __ ] World Series and I am a
fan of another team that was competing
against a two hundred million dollar
team and then we went out and spent buck
ninety two hundred and we had a bunch of
people on Andros Steen and all of that
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ] babies
[ __ ] babies whatever it happens and
then every Oh what did you say what are
we watching
what is it teaching children to do all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] as is it's like are
you paying attention to the news what
corporations do what they do in drinking
water what they do to minorities I mean
get the [ __ ] out of here with this
[ __ ] they always put it on sports go
[ __ ] they put it in sports and they
put it on comedians all right I'm gonna
throw myself in there and make myself a
martyr how about that and now am i
cheating my Bruins lost to the Flies
oops my kids sleeping sorry my Bruins
lost to the Flyers and overtime we got a
point there and then we got shutout
against the Columbus Blue Jackets and
now I'm hoping that we're gonna get back
on track we got the Penguins next but I
am [ __ ] all in back in fro I've been
so damn busy I got the kid up and
running now literally my kids fast too
and she's an athlete and she throws
left-handed and daddy is happy she also
likes dry riding in my old truck she
wants to steer it and all that you know
do you really so cool it is I'm gonna
have a kid that was born in 2017 that
someday is gonna know how to drive three
in a tree a great asset anyway I was
gonna say so you know if you want to get
the quickest way to get back into
[ __ ] hockey if you you know if you
get married you have kids and all that
type of stuff after you get your kids up
and run into that type of [ __ ] daily
faceoff I've been saying it forever okay
it's like a fantasy hockey
website I believe but what they have is
they have the line combinations so you
can easily you can learn your whole team
in like three games I just start yelling
out the numbers like flashcards back in
the day when I was learning the
multiplication tables then once I get
myself down then I just picked like
three other teams that I really like
like right now like if the Bruins aren't
playing or if they play the early game
and if Winnipeg Edmonton or Colorado's
playing I watched those I watched those
three teams I'm really starting to get
to know Edmonton I know they're their
top two nurse in what are the Ethan bear
at least they wear since I've been
watching and I pretty much know that top
two lines and I'm starting to know
Winnipeg and what is it [ __ ] uh
Colorado so that's just what I do I
absolutely [ __ ] love it and I've also
been watching the Celtics but we lost to
the Pistons tonight we got the Bucks
next I'm having a great time well I got
that [ __ ] test on the other side of
me and now you know I got a I got to get
geared up though cuz I'm back on from
being on the road and I gotta start the
the actual flying by instrument lessons
now which is gonna cost a small [ __ ]
fortune I'm not gonna lie there's
nothing I'll tell you there's nothing
cheap sand [ __ ] aviation by the way
thanks to suds them duds for doing the
wash and fold I sent a picture of their
their little how they folded up all my
socks and underwear some put a little
[ __ ] LSU bow on and it was [ __ ]
great seer oh look who's here
I got to do this quietly my wife's
trying to sleep next to me here it's in
the morning oh Jesus Berto don't do me
on dese me on Dee's selling that [ __ ]
cocaine to do do do me on Dee's biondi's
the feds show up in it's lame why the
[ __ ] did you try to do that you're an
old white guy who wears a hat you gotta
get caught sorry I hope they put this in
after the DeLorean [ __ ] it's Valentine's
Day life is in the air Oh
love is in the air even though this is
made up a made-up holiday it's still
really cute it's also the perfect time
to show that special someone how much
you care and save those three words
everyone wants to hear match my undies
see what they did there near me Andes
has the most adorable Valentine's Day
Prince to get all the lovey-dovey this
year oh they're gonna get you laid here
oh good for them
don't worry we got a bunch of wallets on
them sorry uh you can love Oh hua don't
worry if you don't have a boo me undies
also makes bundi bands so you can match
with your pet which is honestly more
important than people roses are red
violets are blue your butt is cute
rhyming is dumb Valentine's Day everyone
not even what that meant okay to show
how much you they love you me undies has
not one but three new Valentine's Day
prints this year the this is this is the
perfect opportunity to show that special
someone you're ready to take it to the
next level with matching pairs match me
so I know it's real is the model this
year if you're matching your BFF or your
dog it still counts also so it's already
got its in the copy someone told us that
me undies as new loungewear rumor has it
that it's loungewear you can wear out
and about keep your eyes peeled for some
cozy new additions the undies has a
great offer from my listeners for any
first-time purchase or you get up 15%
off and free shipping this is a
no-brainer especially because we have a
100% satisfaction guarantee
to get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies dot-com / /
that's
me and East calm / burr oh now we got
hymns look at me Mia I'm livid I don't
even got enough yet and I'm already
going to work crushing it you know do
you respect that well do ya hymns why do
guys turn weird - weird solutions or do
nothing when they can turn to medicine
and science for hymns calm a one time
shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for men you ready for this Nia
you ready for a cleared skin BB with a
big orange lion mane crawling over to
your side of the bed it's time to write
a new chapter one in which you have hair
thanks to science baldness can be
optional is that right hims is helping
guys be the best version of themselves
with licensed physicians and
fda-approved products to help treat hair
loss no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science hims was
created by a guy who knows some men's
health conversations are easier online
than in-person what I'm doing what's his
face from the Warriors it wasn't us
who's them the Warriors for hims
connects you to real doctors online it's
stupid it makes people listen which
could save you hours completely
confidential indiscreet answer a few
quick questions a doctor will review and
if they determine it's right for you can
prescribe you medication to treat your
hair loss that is shipped directly to
your door this holiday season let it
grow let it grow let it grow I get it
let it grow let it grow let it grow
that's cute right do you for hims
do dive into 20/20 hair first right now
my listeners can get started with their
first month for free
go to free him stop calm slash bird
that's for hims calm flourish per
prescription requires an online
consultation with the physician
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate only valid offer valid only
have prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply
see website for full details and
important safety information
remember that's for hims com / burg by
the way on the flight back Oh Billy
movies here you know Oh Billy
cross-country I always try to watch
something different you know it sucked
as they had like three Asian movies on
the plane and they all sucked like Asian
cinema is [ __ ] amazing [ __ ]
amazing and they put in like three lame
ones on there you know the guy next to
me is like hey you know cuz he saw me I
was scrolling his trying to find
somebody goes you look like you
struggling check this movie out as he
goes it's it's an easy no-brainer movie
and I was looking at the movies that
Kang's I can see that anywhere and then
I saw that there was like three movies
like I think I think they were all I
don't know where they were made it was
Korean or China or whatever but the
first one they were speaking English
that annoyed me some like [ __ ] this
movie right I want the subtitles I want
the real [ __ ] right I want to see the
ones that they watch over there
and I don't know what the names of the
movies were but they would just they
just they just were [ __ ] lame they
weren't good ones so I was disappointed
in that so I was like an ass [ __ ] this
maybe I'll I watch a documentary and I
found this thing on John DeLorean it's
called framing DeLorean I think that
John DeLorean John DeLorean course made
that infamously made the the DeLorean
car and that his legal troubles and all
of this type of [ __ ] you got to watch
that thing because I learned so much
about this guy and actually we also
learned about GM in the 14th floor was
where all these executives were trying
to work their way up and I said just a
really amazing time in history where you
could like start in a mailroom at this
giant corporation and they actually made
[ __ ] in this country and you could work
your way up from that granite if you
were white male whose kid no because the
whole 14th floor was like beyond [ __ ]
white
but that doesn't really even exist I
don't feel like a place that actually
build something like back in the day
when you could drive down the street the
way I remember I still remember those
guys was like they'd like they used to
you know work at factories and [ __ ] like
that when I first started doing the rows
one of the last gas with air of the
making [ __ ] in here and there was people
who just think they you know you know if
you worked if you worked at the [ __ ]
Plymouth Division any time you saw a
Plymouth you know it was the probably
whatever the the model car you know
you're like I probably worked on that
car you had like that sense of pride
that you [ __ ] built the thing so
anyways he was a GM and I didn't know
this guy he was in with Pontiac and
Pontiac
I guess it's skewed really old they
called it their old lady division and it
just was not a car that any young people
were into and it wasn't an exciting car
and they were actually considering
getting rid of the line and he came in
and he was the guy that decided what
they had a midsize car forget what it
was called and he took the Chevy
big-block which you weren't supposed to
do I guess they only kept that for like
the Cadillacs or something like that he
took a big-block engine and he stuck it
in that car so the people not on the
14th floor were like dude what the [ __ ]
are you doing he goes Donna you know
we're only gonna make like 4,000 of
these no big deal it's just it's just a
package you know and he just made like
this [ __ ] you know muscle car that
became the GTO and he snuck at PI by the
14th floor he found this [ __ ] angle
and he took like this risk and they
ended up selling like 30 or 40 thousand
of them it became like this unbelievable
thing and he don't that amongst you know
with the other cars what Ford was doing
in Chrysler and all that really kind of
jump-started the whole thing now I
didn't know any of that stuff he was
always known as the guy who tried to get
this car going and then he did a bad
cocaine deal but this thing actually
like I didn't realize that John DeLorean
not only got acquitted that he then got
brought up on other [ __ ] charges of
misappropriating funds
like it was really like just I don't
know I feel like now I'm gonna ruin the
thing but just sit down and watch it
it's an Alec but they do this really
cool documentary where they're talking
about him and then they have Alec
Baldwin playing John DeLorean and they
reenact a lot of these scenes to add to
the documentary it was [ __ ]
incredible check that out if you get a
chance and I think that's it other than
that I want to watch 19:17 I got a
screener you're probably asking yourself
oh did I wake her up no what are you
doing boo bear are you supposed to be in
bed by the way I'm recording this at
nine eleven and you're still at night
and you're still up what am i doing oh
you did okay alright well I'm in the
middle of doing my podcast here so come
over here really quickly
alright you're getting so big I was
telling everybody how fast you could run
tonight you could throw left handed
you're gonna give me a cheese
half-asleep give me a kiss what thank
you love you buddy
okay we gonna play tomorrow riding bikes
yeah all right I gotta wrap this up
bye bye give me five there you go nice
five look at you two adorable adorable
anyway so alright so I'm an old dad
right so you know I got to watch my
vices cuz I gotta be around here I gotta
try to [ __ ] stretch this out here as
long as I can't so I am toying with the
eye I'm gonna quit cigars and I think I
kind of already did I just had to like I
don't know there's so much fun though
but I they they have gotten out of
control the way my drinking got out of
control it's just it's becoming like
a four time a week fight it's like what
am i doing what am i a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I make money running my Yap and I'm
[ __ ] with you know my mouth and my
throat this is stupid
so I got a layoff and if you're gonna
quit cigars a great time to do it is
right after you [ __ ] came back from
New Orleans I actually had a buddy of
mine who came in for the game you ever
just didn't know your buddy was coming
right and all of a sudden said where are
you because I texted that suds and I
knew I was too and he came over and I
had this [ __ ] little balcony thing
and it was hilarious it was like me and
like [ __ ] you know seven other people
who just standing out there talking
sports Bourbon Street was down the
street you know and now we've smoking
cigars just laughing our asses off
having a great time and and then it was
just great cuz we're all just older guys
and we all had kids you know and that
type of [ __ ] and was so [ __ ] perfect
right around 11 o'clock at night one if
somebody just goes should we call it we
calling it and every just goes like yeah
yeah let's call it let's call it we got
a big day tomorrow we got to watch again
oh yeah great perfect the old us would
have been out till 4:00 or 5:00 in the
frame it just would have been draggin
ass somebody would have passed out
during the [ __ ] game like I'm just
I'm beyond any of that stuff and you
know it's funny it's funny even though I
would have loved to continue going so I
think I am done I think I'm done with
cigars I'm done for well I'm taking I'm
taking a significant break at least
because this is the deal you know if you
don't have any vice you know unless
you're wired like Ralph Nader I mean I
don't know like what do you do like what
what am I supposed to do over here you
know I'm just supposed to just I got a
couple friends of mine like that who are
like legit sober you know it's
incredible they don't smoke they don't
drink they don't you know smoke weed
they don't take the occasional edible
they do nothing they are so
just everyday taking life in the [ __ ]
chops every [ __ ] day just dealing
with life I mean it's really [ __ ]
amazing it's the reason why I think you
have booze in drugs because this you
know when you have a long day is there's
nothing better if you could just have
one just having one right I don't know
it's so [ __ ] we I don't know how the
[ __ ] I kind of lost the ability to do
that but I'm smart enough to know that I
don't like [ __ ] with it so yeah so I
am on a cigar sabbatical we'll call it
that like you know I got some [ __ ]
coming up like I don't know I'm
definitely not smoking for the rest of
this month and I don't think I'm I'm not
smoking next month you know and then
I'll see where I'm at and if I just
don't give a [ __ ] anymore than I think
I'm done but oh man that's gonna be
tough
then what do I do what am I left with
huh yeah beautiful wife and a beautiful
kid that I can [ __ ] hang out with for
as long as humanly possible there you go
they go I see you got to think it
through you got to think it through all
right that is the podcast everybody
congratulations to the LSU Tigers way I
had a bad I've been a fan of this since
Oh 8 way back Les Miles watching them
year after year after year after year
rootin for him and a tour on the work
that he did Joe burrow all of those guys
it was just you know Randy Moss his son
is whatever his knee I didn't know I
don't know the names that well Jefferson
I know a few of them but it was just
amazing to watch and just to be at that
game was incredible and I checked
another you know I guess sports
experience off I been to a Super Bowl
both college and pro that's pretty cool
you know here's one it says anybody ever
been to all the WNBA teams to go to here
we've got to be at this point how long
they've been I know they're starting to
dunk you can always get great seats you
know and at the end of the day you're
watching people playing hoop at a high
level why the [ __ ] not
what's the LA tène the LA support you
this is a fight is now this is when you
know this is when you know sports trivia
when you can name all the WNBA
[ __ ] WNBA teams all right let's
see here WNBA teams let's see the
Atlanta Dream Jesus Chicago sky the
Connecticut Sun can you give the ladies
a little more [ __ ] tougher names here
the Indiana Fever the New York Liberty
all right Washington Mystics the Las
Vegas aces aces is a bed Los Angeles
Sparks could be a little more explosive
than just a spark okay the Minnesota
Lynx that's cool you picked an animal
that no one else has the Phoenix Mercury
is that like two astrological signs in
the Seattle Storm wait a minute wait a
minute oh I miss to Dallas wings one two
three four five six I'm just gonna I'm
gonna [ __ ] do this alright let me
believe let me look at the LB plan yet
or they play what they play over the
summer right see here the Los Angeles
Sparks September semi final game regular
season oh it starts in May well that's
unfortunate right as the NBA playoffs
are going it's the end of May though and
it wraps up September 8th is their last
one so when is the
championship game oh I guess it's in
mid-september the semi-finals okay
that's not bad play in these [ __ ]
arenas so who knows alright I think
that's it is that the it for the podcast
I finally turned the corner with my
shoulder I'm back in the gym I'm joining
a gym tomorrow Oh Billy [ __ ] fly
weights is back and I'm getting it
myself I'm already in good shape I'm
eating myself an exceptional shape it's
my goal here and then I'm gonna um I
don't know I got to get back to doing
the pull-ups cuz I got that bet with
virzi that I'm gonna be able to do 10
when I turned 70 I've told you this
before I haven't got a pull-up since my
first shoulder got [ __ ] up when I was
47 and I didn't know how to rehab it and
I just babied it and then it became
frozen and became this [ __ ] took
forever and then guess what my left
shoulder went and you know what that I
did I [ __ ] learn anything now I let
that baby dad then that thing got frozen
but now I've come out of it I do my
stretches every night I [ __ ] you know
move the arm all around I got I got a
hundred percent [ __ ] movement on it
now I'm loving life gonna get back in
the gym throw the weights around and my
goal is to be in an action movie is that
older bald guy who the hero kills that's
the physique I want all right you guys
go [ __ ] yourselves
I will see I'll see you know I'd you
know I'd have a wonderful weekend how
about that I might I say something nice
by the way I just did all the track
names for my Madison Square Garden
recording that I'm going to be releasing
on vinyl it's gonna be this [ __ ] the
album the cover art looks amazing it
sounds amazing
it's it's the paper tiger act plus like
an extra half hour plus it was different
and just the tone of it it's already
kind of an interesting thing to listen
to where I couldn't
how many times I would say a joke and
then make fun of somebody getting
offended by like cuz I don't there was
that time for like 18 months will you be
on stage just thinking like is this the
one is this the one where I become part
of that [ __ ] and get in trouble for
doing nothing but telling jokes you know
there was really like as much as I was
trying to act like it wasn't in my head
it was completely in my [ __ ] head so
just going back and listening myself it
was interesting so hopefully you guys
will think it the same thing so I don't
know how long it's gonna take I mean I'm
almost done completing this and then
I'll let you know because I do have a
contractual thing with Netflix like I
can't have overlapping material there's
like a certain percentage but like it
has my support the troops hero first
responder chunk that didn't make paper
tiger its God I mean I think the whole
first side like nothing is even from the
special so I was really amazed how much
different material is in it and then
even the jokes that overlap I tell him
differently every night and there was
sections I'll see how [ __ ] I forgot to
do that during the special so it's
interesting somebody I'm not colliding
it's for 100% total geek comedy nerds
which is why I put it on a vinyl cuz you
know I just figured people who are
totally [ __ ] into it will then then
get it I don't want to be like I don't
know who knows maybe I'll [ __ ] do a
did you know if you guys want me to do
it like that
maybe after I do the vinyl thing later
on I can do that I don't [ __ ] know
all right that's it that's the podcast
enjoy the music here and then after that
there'll be a bonus half hour of a great
assist Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcasts from a
Thursday I don't know I think he's been
doing him like six seven years ago
alright that's it I'll talk to you on
Monday
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
January 16th 2012
sorry what's going on what 22 the 1 - Z
[ __ ] this is the Monday morning podcast
I am your host I just woke up
I got nothing funny to say I don't have
any goddamn nourishment in me I just
woke up cuz I have a doo doo doo doo
dude I got out of the bed um yeah I
didn't he I'm [ __ ] in my bathrobe and
slippers you know I'm dressed like a
sitcom dad in the morning you know they
dress him up like he never [ __ ] his
wife ever
he had the immaculate conception that's
how they had the kids my mother used to
do that back in the day like with like
Hugh Beaumont a Robert Young or uh Mike
Brady remember they slept in two
separate beds this has been covered
before you know I'm just saying and yes
I do have a bathrobe I always wanted one
when I was a kid you know but my parents
were just like what are you a [ __ ]
are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] what kind of
what kind of a man to be once a goddamn
robe and I was like what about all the
kings at war him and they were like well
what about all the Queens and I was like
you know what I can't refute that how
does that make you feel good about
yourself winning a debate with a [ __ ]
third grader you know I was actually
thinking about this [ __ ] the other day
and I'll probably talk about this on
stage someday cuz I think it's I think
it's funny enough that I'm just not
gonna do it once here in the podcast
I've made that decision see all these
jokes you know it's like it's like one
of those guys who's next to one of those
barrels and he's drinking the [ __ ]
whiskey trying to see if it's okay to
give to the public you know reality's
just a [ __ ] alcoholic who got his
dream job
kind of like how those pedophiles always
somehow get to work at camps you know I
think we really have to revamp that
whole follow your dream should be follow
your dream and unless unless you're a
pedophile you know go follow your heart
you know go right down that road unless
you want to [ __ ] a kid then [ __ ] your
dreams I'm sorry you know built a little
early in the morning for some fat a
pedophile humor well I don't give a [ __ ]
I haven't had toast yet you know I woke
up this morning boo doo doo doo dude and
all I heard was the [ __ ] guilt trip
from you guys when we do folks who
[ __ ] podcast I know I know I'm a
little late little late like you I
watched a lot of football this weekend
didn't I didn't I speaking of that I got
a nice email from a football fan it says
from a Broncos fan bill go [ __ ] yourself
you know what he's just saying he's just
saying you know what I got to admit
they're red-faced you were actually
right last week huh how do you guys feel
how do you guys feel now I'm not talking
about Bronco fans okay I'm not gonna
single your [ __ ] out all right
I got sympathy for you
I know what that's like to be like here
we go we're gonna win the shiny thing
that I never get to touch and somehow
I'll be fulfilled for 20 minutes before
I realize I really had nothing to do
with it and I hate my wife again right
I'm not [ __ ] on you guys my
condolences you know you're great fans I
don't like your new stadium though I
like Mile High I went to a game out
there long [ __ ] time ago
back in 1999 old Johnny boy had just
left he was like I don't need this [ __ ]
I'm gonna go sell some campers in our
beefs come on down to John Elway's big
teeth and weird face Ford will give you
an f-150 or my name isn't Johnny Elway
all right you remember those commercials
so don't really just trash a
first-ballot Hall of Famer I think I did
there's an arrogance you have when
you're wearing a bathrobe
it just says
this is my [ __ ] place all right give
me that goddamn newspaper is that what
it says bill I don't know it says
something making me swing my foot around
for some [ __ ] reason I gotta get a
pipe um the [ __ ] was I talking about
oh yeah I went to a Broncos game a long
time ago in Mile High Stadium shaped
like a horseshoe the whole thing [ __ ]
made sense it all made sense I went to
the Broncos Jets and that was the year
that the J ETS Jets Jets Jets this was
yet another year where those poor green
[ __ ] fans that they have was sitting
there going this is the year we got
Parcells we got Keyshawn we got bill you
know we got [ __ ] Vinny Oh
Testaverde right and what happens first
game Vinny blows out his [ __ ] linguine
of a goddamn what do you call it as a
Kelly's he goes down Johnny he's not
there for the Broncos this was supposed
to be a big game this is supposed to be
for know versus for know and ended up
being Owen four versus Owen four
Keyshawn Johnson was crying because they
didn't have a quarterback and there was
nobody there to give him the damn ball
and and I showed up and the scalpers had
tons of tickets and I was like how much
are they and they're like face value and
I did I didn't even try to knock anymore
off I was like you know what not only is
that selling a good deal I think that's
legal if you ever look on the back of a
lot of those tickets it says you can you
can't sell it for any more or less than
what it's worth but you can't sell it
for what it is worth at least you could
back pre 9/11 you know pre 9/11 you
could do that [ __ ] so anyways I'm
talking about all you other
[ __ ] who just got caught up and
that Tim Tebow hype huh did I get any
emails from you going you know what
Billy I think you were right I think you
hit the nail right on the head
you
which is the perfect expression when
you're talking about a Jesus freaking
right am I really gonna go do this
redneck tour in a couple of weeks with
all these Jesus jokes I really got to
find another person to make fun of when
it comes to religion I just don't know
anything else cuz you know I'm not
well-read I don't know what you guys
worship what do you guys worship up
there in Canada huh some sort of six
legged moose that's that's also mad and
it's gonna come back and [ __ ] do
something to you there's always look at
Jesus coming back okay there's one of
him this 7 billion of us so I don't
understand what the [ __ ] was so afraid
of you know would you swarm him just
hold him down you don't beat him up you
just hold him down all right you're
right G stop struggling you're right
you're right we could be doing better
all right well what are you eating so
[ __ ] mad at I thought that was one of
the deadly sins huh with your wrath his
revenge is revenge one of the deadly
sins it should be anytime I try to
remember that the deadly sins you know I
just think of Morgan Freeman standing in
the rain 7 what the [ __ ] will they agree
gluttony pride sloth Envy lust and wrath
so revenge isn't in there but there is
that vengeance is mine said it the Lord
won't you stop being so selfish Lord and
why don't you spread it around all right
what the [ __ ] am I talking about I said
at least had an English muffin you know
you guys think this being funny [ __ ]
he's easy you can't do it on an empty
stomach
it's like boozing on an empty stomach or
[ __ ] something else on an empty
stomach cuz my brains not all [ __ ]
awake yet we can tell it's not a wake
bill because now you're dropping the
f-bomb where you don't even need to
close my brains not [ __ ] awake yet
alright now the worst thing you can do
when you got nothing is to start
heckling yourself what you're supposed
to do in show business is just put on a
smile and start tap dancing and just
plowing your [ __ ] way through it so
let's get on with this [ __ ] I told you
[ __ ] last week that Tim Tebow
as of right now it's not an NFL
quarterback all right and all you
[ __ ] fans were sending me
emails giving me [ __ ] go when you're not
giving him any [ __ ] credit including
Paul versi New Jersey's own Paul virzi
who's now moved to Albany so he
considers himself in New Yorker but he's
not fooling anybody
you know we can smell Newark on you Paul
he was another guy going yeah you know
you got to give the guy credit you got
to give the guy credit credit for what
that he beat a team that totally played
into his hand hey this guy's running a
high school offense I have an idea let's
let's give him a high school defense and
all he's got to do is beat single
coverage holy [ __ ] he did it 10 out of
21 times see what happens when you go
when you face a real [ __ ] team 45 to
[ __ ] 10
haven't said that I think the guy's a
phenomenal athlete but I think he's a
phenomenal athlete in the Jim Thorpe
sense in the Bruce Jenner sense I think
this guy is a decathlete that's what he
is it's not quite big enough to be a
quarterback he's a little too small to
be a tight end he's a little too thick
to be a [ __ ] wide receiver but the
guy can [ __ ] play
he's got the intangibles he's a [ __ ]
leader I think he's gonna survive I
don't know what he's gonna do
who knows maybe he'll be a quarterback
all right now with that footwork though
can you can't believe the [ __ ]
arrogance of me the way I trash these
[ __ ] professional athletes as if I
ever played the game you know what's
even more amazing is you sit there and
you [ __ ] listen to it so what's wrong
with you like that I'm passing the buck
I don't know
so do we got next week the Patriots got
the Ravens Jesus Christ we actually play
a [ __ ]
real defense but you know something I'm
not buying into Joe Flacco I really
don't I don't buy anything that guy I
have no idea but I got to tell you this
there's another thing I [ __ ] called
this is just gonna be the arrogant
podcast once you guys go back a couple
whatever the week it was the Monday
after the Giants lost to the Packers
remember that and I said it eerily
looked like when the Patriots beat the
Giants that year we went 60 nano we beat
the Giants the final game of the year
yet we gave up like 30-something points
and for some reason a month later we
were like 15 point favorites in the
Super Bowl and what happened they came
back to beat us so my prediction was
that Eli Manning was gonna go into Green
Bay was gonna beat an undefeated Packers
team go on to win the Super Bowl
at which point their B's second ring
he'd be bigger than Joe Namath and
Peyton Manning would then become the
second best quarterback in that house
that was my prediction the only thing
that didn't [ __ ] happen was the
Packers weren't [ __ ] undefeated so how
about you [ __ ] givin me a little bit
of credit that like once one out of
every 22,000 predictions I have actually
comes in that's a pretty good average
right well go fine I don't give a [ __ ]
what my the only guy was weird when that
guy in the 49ers bursted into tears if
you really look at Jim Harbaugh's face
you could see him he's like okay here we
go
grown man crying I don't know what he's
crying about he scored a touchdown did
he come back from some sort of horrific
injury did he beat like Ebola or
something because that looked like the
ending of like an after-school special
he scored the touchdown he got up
instead of being like you know it's
actually a great thing that he [ __ ]
cried but yeah you just as a guy you
just have to look away
you know there's no crying in football
come on hold it together right you're
supposed to get up like yeah this is
what the [ __ ] we do here in San
Francisco you're not supposed to get up
and start crying like [ __ ] a dead Ed
McMahon showed up with one of those
giant Publishers Clearing House checks
you know and you've been eating meals
off a Forman grill for the last [ __ ]
90 years you're supposed to catch the
ball
you're supposed to spike it and do your
little [ __ ] give me a sneaker deal
dance that's what the [ __ ] you're
supposed to do and if you got a cry for
the love of God keep your [ __ ] helmet
on so the rest of us don't have to feel
uncomfortable is that the worst that was
so uncomfortable then every woman in the
rooms like I think that's nice I think
what he's happy he should they're so
full of [ __ ] all they see is a weak man
that they can manipulate I could go out
with some guy like that then whenever I
cut off the [ __ ] cuz he's not doing
what I'm good I wanted to do he's gonna
start crying god help me if I ever meet
that [ __ ] specimen hey there's a
prediction which professional athlete is
gonna be sent a clip of this show and
body slam me first that's gonna be
[ __ ] ugly it's really gonna be ugly
it's bad enough that I have the physique
of a person who's been doing comedy for
the last 20 years but what makes it even
[ __ ] worse is the pace dienes of my
skin so whenever I get hit like the
bruise you can see everywhere when you
have when you have no pigment people
what I'm telling you his first it turns
red and then and then it becomes a deep
purple that would be [ __ ] hilarious
what's his name Vernon Davis I don't
[ __ ] know um if he [ __ ] bodyslam
me and then I got up and then I started
crying
except I was crying because it hurt
rather than I achieved a monumental goal
is that legal can anybody take out the
guy manual is that okay to [ __ ] cry
you know you don't happen yesterday was
he watching that that [ __ ] the end of
uh
the hell was that goddamn who the hell
was playing this tail the green Green
Bay Giants game we watched the end of
that game and then immediately Nia
switched over to the [ __ ] Golden
Globes and she was as into that [ __ ] as
I was into football and I of course just
started [ __ ] on everybody you know
stupid [ __ ] award shows and Ricky
Gervais scam out was being cheeky uh
that sheepish smile he kept doing after
every joke just really let me know that
he still wanted to be loved by all those
celebrities and it [ __ ] ruined it for
me
alright she was watching that [ __ ] and
some [ __ ] guy came out did you see
that guy who was speaking like really
slowly the guy who looked like he was
from Transylvania you know via Saudi
Arabia did you see that guy who came up
there was just really slowly going when
I came up here I was thinking I was
going to thank blah blah blah blah that
I thought I would thank Lumumba so we
were doing all these jokes about the guy
saying you have a bomb around my waist
death to Israel and Mia was getting
really mad you know because she's so
she's so like you know don't make fun of
anybody and less their white people with
no teeth in the woods then you can
completely trash them because they're
white and every president except for
this last one has been white evidently
that's okay I know I don't go i [ __ ]
trash every I trash Sidney Poitier and
his [ __ ] attitude coming out she
actually laughed at that his dramatic
pauses none of you deserve to be here I
paved the road and you all shat all over
it I was just doing that like he just
carries himself he's [ __ ] actors I
swear to God
there's something like I you know have
you ever seen a group of people more up
their own ass when they sit there
talking about the character I totally
respect acting I think it's the [ __ ] but
like they put athletes to shame you know
they're basically you know like when
athlete comes on TV you know and then
just like a Joe Blow what happened out
there today well you know Joe Blow when
Joe Blow gets the ball Joe Blow puts it
in the enso cuz that's what Joe Blow
needs to do when Joe Blow needs more
[ __ ] touches right just it's saying
you're talking the [ __ ] third person
they basically do that but with an
accent and everybody all of a sudden
sounds like they're English royalty the
second you do Shakespeare they're like
[ __ ] Madonna Madonna is some skank
from right outside of Detroit and she
walks around like she's been knighted
you know like she came out of one of
those [ __ ] inbred vaginas that sits
in that castle over there in England you
know do you realize how [ __ ] the
overlap in that family tree the royalty
cuz they can't be they can't even be
bothered with breeding with anybody
worth less than twelve billion dollars
you know what I mean that's when you're
just sitting at the end either end of a
long [ __ ] like a 50-yard dining room
table and then like well sis I guess
it's just you and make time to have a
little Prince right that's why I can't
like I love movies in that type of [ __ ]
but I can't sit there and listen to
those [ __ ] people
I just can't listen to when they get up
there they're like you know the crew and
I want to thank all these for shot tough
just grab your shiny thing this is one
thing I gotta tell you though those
[ __ ] you gotta admit every year the
plastic surgery gets a little bit better
you know for as much as you might not
like celebrities those people have been
putting their faces on the line for the
last [ __ ] four
years and it's getting to the point they
almost have it down
they still look weird those like those
chicks in their 50s now who don't have
any wrinkles in their face they still
look weird you know what I mean it's
like when somebody has an old car and
rather than you know doing a body off
restoration on it they just kind of you
know they put some bondo on it and they
[ __ ] give it a nice shiny coat of
paint that's what their faces look like
with that Botox right now I can't see
the dents you can't see the dings you
can't see any of that [ __ ] and I got a
nice shiny lacquer you know three coats
of [ __ ] Botox right across the
forehead I wonder if they still have
like that old person smell wouldn't it
be weird you're looking at him they look
like they're in their 20s there was a
lot of hotties there last night I'm not
gonna lie to you but I got taste some
Angelina Jolie Jesus Christ did she put
on weight or what what a goddamn fatty
she was huh yeesh you know what's funny
is a oh my god Angelina you look so
beautiful tonight look at those
collarbones what do you do how do you
develop those collar but honey make
those so pronounced well every day I eat
a corn flake um am I really sitting here
talking about an award show I am that's
what the [ __ ] I did yesterday i sat
there and I watched that [ __ ]
alright let's let's uh let's hey this is
actually sort of an official podcast now
I actually have some advertisers um for
instance amazon.com everybody do you
guys buy stuff off of amazon.com sure we
all do what is what you do if you want
to if this is the thing if you want to
donate to the podcast like I've been
saying for weeks now all you do just
rather than go on amazon.com if you just
go to billboard.com right I'm doing it
right now
you go to billboard.com you click on the
podcast BAM just like that and then
right there under the iTunes is
amazon.com you click on that you buy
whatever the hell you were gonna buy
anyways and they give me a little
kickback for driving traffic to
amazon.com I take
that kickback do I stick it in my pocket
and drink some booze of course I do but
10% of it I kick over to the Wounded
Warriors Project so there you go and you
know have to do anything else you don't
have to click on some other thing on
amazon.com you just go there and buy
that thing that you probably don't need
if you really sit there and think about
it
amazon.com everybody now seriously a lot
of you guys have been doing it I really
appreciate it and you know cuz
eventually I'm gonna be too old to stand
up and do stand-up comedy which point
I'll start sitting down and it'll get
sad and then each show will just be me
and eight of my hardcore fans in that
town and you're gonna be there and I'm
gonna make you feel old I'm gonna be old
and the whole thing it's just gonna get
ugly alright it's gonna be like seeing
your favorite band 30 years after you
[ __ ] graduated you know they got and
you go down there right they come
[ __ ] limping out and for the first
song and a half they try to recapture
their youth before they just finally say
you know what we're just gonna come out
here and croon shout shout at the devil
how about that shout at the devil he's
the wolf something in the night ladies
he's a blood stain on the stage so
anyways just go to amazon.com and also
everybody uh anybody check out the new
Napoleon Dynamite show last night come
on I know you did yeah last night was
the two episode premiere and I guess it
did great in the ratings and just keep
watching it what's it on Fox at 8:30 and
there you go that was [ __ ] horrific
you know it was was I had to sit here
and I had to hit pause to figure out the
damn TV schedule I'm looking at Fox is
uh they say it's not gonna be on again
until January 29th
Napoleon gets his own dream job as a
liger I just love the fact cuz I love
cartoons and I just love that they got
the original cast backed I think that's
awesome you know is there's nothing
worse than when they try and get like
you know somebody who just sounds like
the guy you know it's like all those
Sinatra impersonators out there and you
know the whole time you just like wow
this guy almost sounds like the guy who
would have sold out Madison Square
Garden but instead we're it we're at an
all all of garden right no geez you know
what I'm gonna do next week
I'm gonna make sure I have a [ __ ]
English muffin before I try this crap
all right please watch the poll Ian
dynamite on FOX 8:30 every goddamn week
they got the original cast I don't know
what more you want we're gonna do how
you gonna watch The Real Housewives how
old are they at this point mm-hmm um if
you guys seen that new [ __ ] movie
Neil was showing me that movie about
that whale those whales trapped under
the ice and Drew Barrymore has like a
[ __ ] romantic moment where she sort
of [ __ ] her head to the side under the
water like a hall I think that whales
communicating with me
that my friends is a high-grade piece of
[ __ ] all right
that's the kind of movie that should
have not even gone to that you know what
that one should go direct to the video
stores because they don't [ __ ] exist
anymore you don't have doing right now I
am burning every [ __ ] possible bridge
that I could even have in this business
because you know why I'm hungry I got my
bathrobe on and I'm feeling entitled oh
he's dangerous he doesn't give a [ __ ] um
all right let's get back to the goddamn
podcast all right state of the country
hello built you've been traveling around
the u.s. a lot in the last decade or two
and since your profession is basically
to observe the world around you I would
like to ask you a question
what changes have you seen in the u.s. I
don't travel much so I would like your
opinion is our country crumbling beneath
us are the potholes bigger in Texas than
in California do people in the red
states have Colt 45 strapped to their
waist
is our population getting Dumber and
fatter what is the biggest change you've
noticed since you started on the road I
would say technology two biggest thinks
the the technology and 911 those are the
things that that changed my world the
most you know when I started people I
guess the internet existed you know what
I mean the way oil existed in the
[ __ ] ground when we were cavemen but
nobody decided to drill it because there
wasn't any cars yet you know no one was
on the [ __ ] Internet all right so I
know nobody had cell phones
nobody had video camera they had that
[ __ ] but it was gigantic so I'm just
talking about me as a [ __ ] performer
like standing on stage now the amount of
people texting or trying to record the
show or just not paying attention
looking at their smartphones while their
faces light up that has changed the
ability for someone to email directly
somebody that they saw on stage and
[ __ ] trash them I would say like that
that's probably the biggest change I've
seen and yes I did make it all about me
as far as the potholes and that type of
stuff and people getting fatter have
they gotten fatter I don't know you know
they were always kind of fat and I just
think that there's just stories that
they like talking about like when I
started out everybody was gonna get AIDS
nobody was safe everybody had to get
tested it was the end of the [ __ ]
world the CIA created it and we were all
gonna die and now if you go in as a
straight guy that'd be like he a head of
section a heterosexual do you shoot
drugs all right I'll test you for it but
I'm telling you you gotta you gotta [ __ ]
like Magic Johnson to get the [ __ ] if
you're in that category you know I'm not
saying you shouldn't wear a condom
because everything else seems to eat
through it and right now that's
disgusting
that's actually a good question what
have I seen that has changed I'll tell
you in the sporting world everybody went
from the old school stadiums that only
sports fans would want to go to because
there was very few luxury boxes and that
type of [ __ ] and all you could get was
beer hot dogs peanuts and regular stuff
and now that they're all these these
fancy ass [ __ ] stadiums that has
changed baseball stadiums baseball
stadiums used to be just when I started
out with dumps and I went to every one
of them County Stadium old Tiger Stadium
Shea Stadium ol Yankee Stadium with a
[ __ ] else that I go Wrigley Field the
Kingdome the Astrodome I went to the
[ __ ] Royals before they fixed it up
some of them were nice Busch Stadium I
went to I went to pretty much everyone
that they knocked down Veterans Stadium
Three Rivers Stadium and I went to all
those and they were [ __ ] dumps but I
loved them because I grew up watching
games there watching this week in
baseball bump bump bump up bad at the
bat the bat ha ha and that show was the
[ __ ] by the way because you didn't have
a 24-hour sports station so once a week
you got to watch the highlights from
around the league
I mean you missed everything you [ __ ]
missed everything used to open the
sports page and he had to squint to find
out what the [ __ ] happened and on any
other sports team besides your own
unless it was the playoffs then then
obviously they would cover it and then
they had the game of the week so I would
say like the biggest thing that has
changed is yeah technology and then 911
you do anything like there's such [ __ ]
on the airline right now because all
they have to do is just bring up 911 you
know that's their version of just
screaming rape you know and then the
bouncer comes over and just [ __ ]
kicks the [ __ ] out of you hey can I get
a pillow please we don't have any pills
why not sir why are you being hostile
why are you a [ __ ] what does that have
to do with terrorism I'm asking for a
[ __ ] pillow sorry so I would say that
that's changed in most other than yet
yeah it's just [ __ ] that you realize
that yeah the big dollar I you know
another thing that's really changed I
don't know what the [ __ ] people do for
jobs anymore when I started as a
comedian it was like well I'm in
construction I'm a dentist I'm like it
was tangible [ __ ] I work in a warehouse
I Drive a truck and now everybody's got
those for those [ __ ] computer jobs I
don't even know what they do I work at a
company we make this do you make it here
no they make it over in Thailand and I'm
some sort of go-between that sits in a
cubicle with reams of paper every day
and I play Angry Birds whenever my dad
my dad one of my boss is it looking I
would say that that's kind of changed
you know but as far as the potholes I
haven't really noticed that it still
looks the same
I'll tell you what is concerning to me
is they have a giant fountain out here
in LA and this year they didn't put that
in lighted up for Christmas you know
everybody has like that one little
touristy attraction thing that you have
and they always light it up during
Christmas right they didn't do that out
here in LA and I find that really
disturbing and did made me want to get a
gun and which I am going to do despite
me is I don't know she kind of like
respects the fact that I want that I
want a gun you know it's weird she's a
typical human being human being typical
broad you know she wants me she like
tries all the time to mold me into her
best girlfriend and then when I fight
her on it she like [ __ ] respects me
but it's still [ __ ] annoyed so like
she's always gonna be mad at me
you just can't [ __ ] win you know
unless you just give in to the fact that
you're gonna argue and it's you know
what it is
surviving in a [ __ ] relationship it's
like World Series of Poker when you
don't really have a good hand but you
just Bluff that you do you just Bluff
that you have a better hand than your
partner and you let go ahead walk away
try and find someone else you know
that's basically what you have to do
every four days you know over anything I
thought I told you to sweep up the floor
right you got to do that every couple of
days I've actually gotten much better at
that [ __ ]
you notice we we moved into a little old
house out here and I realize what a
stereotypical guy am I bitched at first
when Nia took the best room for her
little [ __ ] her little space you know
when I got banished out into the garage
you know just like my [ __ ] bit that I
was doing but I got taste up I [ __ ]
loved the goddamn garage you know this
weekend you know what I did during
playoff football I went out there during
halftime to do my quick little Billy red
face [ __ ] workout you know I bought
this uh I bought this this chin up dip
station standalone thing you know did I
go out and buy the top-of-the-line [ __ ]
no I didn't i bought the hundred $39 one
and i got to tell you it's the [ __ ] sure
it rocks a little bit because my garage
floor isn't level I'll tell you what's
[ __ ] unreal is I got that thing all
right it weighed like 9,000 pounds so I
drag this thing downstairs to the garage
and I [ __ ] you know I'm not the
handiest of people here I didn't grow up
doing that [ __ ] you know I had like one
crescent wrench and a screwdriver and
other than that I had a bunch of wooden
sticks that I pretend what his were guns
and I played cowboy and Indians way
longer than was socially acceptable
that's what I did all right so I get
this [ __ ] thing and I try not to lose
my [ __ ] when I'm putting something
together I saw this thing and right off
the
I'm like this thing's gonna be a
[ __ ] to put together all right
so the first thing I do is I lay out
everything I don't do what I usually do
is I just start putting the thing
together and then get upset when I screw
two things together that that you know
one thing from step one and one thing
from step nine so I lay all this [ __ ]
out you know spend that [ __ ] 15
minutes making sure I have every goddamn
screw and everything and the numbers
aren't adding up okay so I get it -
basically to the point where 80% of it
makes sense to me and I start building
this [ __ ] at about nine o'clock
at night all right
I didn't finish by the time I came
upstairs granted I cleaned up afterwards
it was 108 in the morning [ __ ] you but
every guy put every [ __ ] screw in the
way it was supposed to go if you watched
a fast video of me putting this thing
together you would see me go you know
halfway through step one take it apart
again all the way through step one
halfway through step two back down to
step one all the way to step five back
to step two I just I was getting to the
point I'm like you know I had a 50/50
chance of putting that [ __ ] thing on
the correct way you know right side up
could you know that thing when you go
when you go to lift your knees up to
your chest they got that pad right
behind you so the thing is angled back
45 degree angle backwards and I had it I
had the [ __ ] thing upside down well
now it was like going away from your
body rather than up against it you know
or into your body I should say and I had
already gone through like another
there's one of those things we needed
two Crescent wrenches and all that type
of [ __ ] but I got to tell you something
I [ __ ] finish that and I was only
used up all the screws I only had two
pieces left over and for the [ __ ]
life of me I can't figure out where they
went there's some sort of like these
they look like door hinges so I know
they're supposed to the top half and the
bottom half they're supposed to
reinforce it but for the life of me I
don't know where the [ __ ] they went
because these directions
sucked I know you think I blame in the
directions but I'm telling you they had
a typo on page two where they said you
screw number eighteen that's what the
picture said and then and then the words
underneath it said number nineteen so
what the [ __ ] was I supposed to do go
[ __ ] yourself so anyways I've been
fixing up any what the hell I'm talking
about now I've been fixing up my goddamn
garage and I love it out there I swear
to God I am gonna put a steel door on my
garage that only I have a key to and I'm
just gonna you know whenever Nia pisses
me off I'm just gonna go downstairs to
the garage she can have the rest of
[ __ ] house right is there any problem
in that I don't think there is um so
anyway so I've been telling her I want
to get a gun I want to get I just want
to have one you know just [ __ ] walk
around in my robe with that thing tucked
right into my [ __ ] what the [ __ ] god
dammit what the [ __ ] do you call what
what a terrycloth belt
what the [ __ ] is a bathrobe made out of
all right you know what I guarantee you
this is gonna be the worst podcast of
2012 dumb things I'm never gonna [ __ ]
do one on an empty stomach anyways I'm
wearing my references I don't know where
the [ __ ] they are god damn I'm like so
early in the morning out here my back is
still out that's how old I am I got to
wake up I got to stretch out my [ __ ]
achilles tendons and I have to stretch
my back or when I go into the bathroom
and I [ __ ] brush my teeth if I'm even
slightly bent towards the sink my back
goes out can you [ __ ] believe that
and I've told jokes for the last 20
years all right let's go to the advice
maybe there's some funny over here
advice dear bill when I was a young man
and in high school my parents would
never allow me to be in my bedroom with
a young boy whose parents unless the
door remained open yeah because they
didn't want you to [ __ ]
however I had some lady friends whose
parents would allow us to be in a
bedroom with the door closed and for me
door close equals that young lady is is
getting pounded out parentheses made
love to
yeah that's kind of weird huh that's cuz
women are masters of manipulation guys
like what can't have the door closed I'm
trying to [ __ ] her right that's what we
do but women are just like um just
listen this is I'm trying to have some
me time I just need two door closed
which is I see I don't know what the
[ __ ] they was I don't know how to talk
my way into that anyway so now I'm
getting older I was wondering what kind
of a father I would be door closed or
door open and I have to say if I have a
daughter there would be no way I would
have her in there with some young fella
and my reason would be that I don't want
anybody sticking their dick and my
daughter under my roof and possibly
getting her pregnant absolutely sir
absolutely total logic and then he said
but what if your daughter was gay would
you have the same rules about the
bedroom door there's no threat of
pregnancy and you're no longer
protecting daddy's little girl from the
big bad wolf now think about the same
situation if it were your gay son I'd
love to hear your thoughts um let's see
well first of all you're giving me
credit that I would realize that my son
or daughter was already gay you know so
let's say I realized that um it all
depended on how I handled my son or
daughter being gay you know which is I'd
like to think I could handle it I don't
know I think that that would still be in
a John be totally honest I would still
have to adjust to that just being
totally [ __ ] honest because I don't
have any problem with gay people at all
but I'm not gonna lie to you that what
that would have to be like okay all
right come on bill
be [ __ ] mature about this you know
I'm not mature enough I'd have to deal
with that so would I leave the door
closed I would have a double standard if
it was a couple of ladies it wouldn't
bug me but if it was guys I'd be like
hey guys can't leave the [ __ ] door
open okay
oh you can hold hands but for me for me
could you just do a
your dad alright we just delay this for
a minute and just let me wrap my [ __ ]
head around this alright I've already
given up on the fact that that you're
gonna [ __ ] follow in my footsteps now
I have to deal with this alright
that's totally [ __ ] honest and I'm
sure people will be like that's [ __ ]
homophobic which I love which I love you
know being honest is [ __ ] homophobic
you know when I just [ __ ] said what
most people would actually probably do
it's a [ __ ] it's an adjustment any time
it's just like any any time your kid you
know your daughter comes home she shaved
half her [ __ ] head alright yeah and
she died the other side blue you can be
like do you know what the [ __ ] did you
do you stepped outside than do everybody
else you're gonna freak out a little bit
rather than looking at it like you know
what that takes a lot of balls that's
actually you really don't give a [ __ ]
what other people think that's a very
strong thing to do with that age I
didn't have the balls to do that this
actually this exercise will help you
become a better person you know you got
to go through the freakout first so I'm
just being on being honest you know Nia
wouldn't give a [ __ ] you know which is
why I'm with her she balances me out so
go [ __ ] yourselves I don't need a
lecture
all right you [ __ ] alright alright
number two bill I've had this girl who's
been a friend since pre-kindergarten who
I I have had a crush on since then I
have asked her out I think since middle
school
now we're freshmen in college and each
time she has turned me down you know
what I'm still thinking about that other
one all right let's say I had three kids
and two of them were clearly straight
and one of them was gay that'd be a lot
easier today all right [ __ ] it you know
and this isn't homophobic this all has
to do with me and my own insecurities
you know because every guy you're gonna
start off you want your kid to be
quarterback of the [ __ ] football team
and then all of a sudden the dudes
RuPaul and bar on your mom's clothes I
mean there's gonna be a moment you can
be like [ __ ] before you deal with me
like you know what that's my son I love
him no matter what that's where I would
up he's my son I love him no matter what
but I would I would have to adjust you
know aren't I allowed that am I allowed
an adjustment well why do you have to
adjust I don't [ __ ] because I do look
I don't even like people touching me
okay I got a lot of things I have to
adjust on you know I was down the comedy
store last night and Bobby Lee whenever
he talks to me
he always [ __ ] touches me cuz he
knows I can't [ __ ] stand it but Bobby
is just small enough where you can't get
mad at him
like he knows you're not gonna do
anything to him so that's what he does
and the more uncomfortable you get the
more effeminately he'll touch your
shoulder and he just laughs his ass off
at your right so I'll [ __ ] you I got
issues all right but my heart's open so
go [ __ ] yourselves all right number two
bill I've had a crush I've had this girl
I've been friends with since
pre-kindergarten who I've had a crush on
since then I have asked her out I think
some think since middle school
now we're freshmen in college and each
time she has turned me down so I've been
cool with it until a couple of months
ago month ago when she starts dating my
best friend oh Jesus
there's a nice [ __ ] kick to you this
caught me off guard but after some time
their relationship falls apart I asked
my best friend if it was cool if I try
my hand at dating her he was cool with
it so we started hanging out going to
the movies out to eat cuddling at her
place dude this is brutal so what have
you fall in love with this and then your
best friend's already banged her you
know then you got to deal with that
anyway so during this time I would ask
her out and she always had an excuse her
dad was racist not a good time in her
life dude talk about the opposite the
entire spectrum of excuses
my dad's racist this just isn't a good
time in my life my mom thinks you people
should be a Lim
from the planet I got my period good
lord
um anyways but three weeks ago she
Springs a [ __ ] surprise on me she
tells me that she started she's starting
dating an older guy as we were snuggling
up on the couch and she wants me to meet
him
alright you know what I don't know how
many more [ __ ] red flags you need
that this girl is out of her [ __ ]
mind she's all over the place and you're
sitting there coming up with your heart
right on one of those silver [ __ ]
trays you standing there dressed like
like the goddamn Butler and Batman just
lining yourself up for this
anyway she goes the guy look like Brian
Posehn and Artie Lange had a lovechild -
the funniest [ __ ] guys I know by the
way okay
I'm not trashing either one of them I'm
just reading this [ __ ] email but
here's the problem
she still flirts with me and invites me
over to her house and we cuddle go to
the movies all that so does she want me
or she's just or she just [ __ ] with
me dude now I know all of that was in
your head and then you wrote it all
right but now that you've heard me read
it out loud don't you already have your
answer alright and I'm not judging you
cuz I've been that age I've been that
[ __ ] age all right where you're just
sitting there you're so into somebody
that you're just you know and then you
go through the [ __ ] you get your
heart stomped on and it takes a good two
three [ __ ] years later before you
look back on a go I am or I almost I did
in a weird way deserve that I was so
[ __ ] stupid you know I mean what
you're doing with your heart is the
equivalent of going up going to the zoo
and walking up to like the polar bear
you know encasement and just jumping
into the water and as the polar bear is
going to the watery like am I crazy or
is that thing gonna maul me to death um
yeah this girl's out of her mind she's
out of her mind and she's not gonna [ __ ]
you because you're sitting there
cuddling with her the more you're
cuddling with her with her all you're
doing is is your build every day you're
at
another row of bricks between you and
her [ __ ] okay so what you gotta do is
just leave this girl alone okay and if
she ever comes back into your life
there's got to be enough time and then
just go into the two-minute offense
all right no huddle hurry up offense and
then maybe you can bang her all right
that's it all right see look at this I
already feel bad about saying that that
whole thing about having a gay kid see
that that's all it took it just took ten
minutes ten minutes all right this deal
if I had a gay kid it wouldn't be able
to get past it it wouldn't bug me but
you can't close the door if you guys if
your women have at it I have a double
standard go [ __ ] yourself all right son
you can be gay but you gotta be on top
that's it all right because you can't be
a bottom until you move out of this
house all right that's it um all right
number with a [ __ ] my number three
all right there bill last year I broke
up with my girlfriend of two years she
was always kind of a basket case but
nothing ever too severe
towards the end of the relationship she
began to treat me like [ __ ] especially
when she was drunk in public yeah
because she wanted to break up with you
and didn't know how that's probably why
finally I called it quits however being
the horny lazy 21 year old I am let me
guess you ran right back to the hornet's
nest didn't you I decided to keep
hooking up with her for several months
everything but sex Jesus yes she's
slowly tearing the band-aid off this
seemingly worked out because we shared a
group of friends and everything seemed
fine yes I know I was an idiot all right
I'm gonna guess where this is gonna go
one night she starts making out with
like your best friend that's what I'm
guessing are eventually I start telling
her that was going to try and see other
girls and that we should stop but when
it didn't work out with them I went back
to getting with her yeah dude you
[ __ ] lazy
what are you doing so finally after
months of this [ __ ] I told her that
enough was enough it was at this point
that she confessed to me she had been
with a very good friend of mine bang
several times now I know what you guys
are thinking he reads this [ __ ] before
no I didn't I swear to God all right I
already called the Giants beat in the
[ __ ] Packers a month ago I don't need
to be right about this all right this is
all out of experience oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] here we go
with a very good friend of mine several
times both before and after Oh before
and after our breakup now why did she
confess that to you you know what it is
there's such [ __ ] [ __ ]
she kept you around because you know she
was getting over you and now you pulled
the ripcord first which is what she
wanted to do so now what she's trying to
do is she's trying to hurt you
so she has to tell you that there's such
[ __ ] you know something I wouldn't even
know if I broke up with Nia how does
somehow insert myself into her
friendship with her best friends to
[ __ ] ruin that anyways when I asked
her questions she said she made out with
them several times and they had had a
couple of [ __ ] slash fingering
escapades at this point I was [ __ ]
furious but I kept my cool that's good
man don't give her that satisfaction
I showed up unannounced at his place the
next day and asked him if it was true he
told me that she was lying and that they
had only drunkenly made out once after
the breakup I went back and forth
between the two of them until finally he
fessed up and confirmed that her story
was true I haven't spoken to him since
around August and since then I have
ceased contact with the ex-girlfriend
and have a new 10 times better
girlfriend in my life more sex nicer non
psycho good for you the other gate the
other day the guy texted me with this I
was wondering if I could take you to
coffee or something soon I want to
apologize and
person if not I understand to which I
replied I'll be in touch this guy was a
dear friend of mine and since I found
out about the cheating he has
respectfully kept his distance despite
the fact that he used to be at my place
all the time and still hangs out with my
roommates in addition and the next few
months we'll be working together on a
project for school and there's nothing I
can do to change that what should I do
here I'm not really a grudge holding
kind of guy but this [ __ ] was
screwing around my girl one minute than
hanging out with me the next in addition
the girls the girls said that the reason
she started acting so mean towards me
now so mean to me towards the end of the
relationship was because of the guilt
she had regarding the cheating [ __ ]
broads he writes and the guy tried to
weasel his way out of it when I
confronted him with the truth it's the
worst I've ever been betrayed by a
friend I don't know if I could stomach
having this guy hanging out with my
roommates in my house knowing what he
did but some say forgiveness is better
than staying angry I don't want to look
like a [ __ ] that can be walked over
what should I do
alright the vindictive side of me says
go back and become best friends with
this guy and then run into your
ex-girlfriend and [ __ ] laugh at her
as you compare notes about what's the
best way to finger her alright which is
stupid this is what you should do meet
the guy for coffee you know he says he's
sorry say hey don't worry about it and
when he says hey can we be friends again
be like now no we can't I totally
forgive you god bless you good luck in
life I look forward to working with you
on this project but now we can't be
friends you know your goddamn Fox in the
[ __ ] henhouse I'm gonna let you back
in the henhouse go [ __ ] yourself I got a
new girlfriend she's ten times better
looking you know you did me a favor good
luck but you know what dude I know you
feel bad about what you did but at the
end of the day you're a guy who will try
and [ __ ] your best friend's girlfriend I
don't want a friend like that in my life
okay but you don't have to feel awkward
around me I'll see you in the [ __ ]
bars we'll fist bump and all
[ __ ] I'll have a beer with you but no
that's it and there you go
and that's your keys to happiness right
there you got to cut people out [ __ ]
that guy if that guy was in the mob what
he did he would get whacked okay so what
you're doing is you're not in the mob
you know you're gonna whack this guy in
a way that when you're not in a mob
which is you're just like oh my god I'm
like though not talking to you that's
what people who aren't the mob I forgot
to [ __ ] him [ __ ] that guy you know I
know he's young and [ __ ] immature
there maybe 10 years down the [ __ ]
road when he's married and miserable or
whatever who knows but dude you don't
you don't need [ __ ] like that this is
your life right now you're trying to
find the right [ __ ] woman you're
gonna spend the rest of your life with
and then you got to put together your
[ __ ] untouchables your group of
friends you want to have friends that
you know that if you were away he said
hey look after my girl teeth the guy
wouldn't try and [ __ ] her that's a very
hard fine that's a very hard friend to
find and that guy isn't he he flunked
the test the lock the door test don't
don't figure my girlfriend when I'm not
around tests he flunked it you [ __ ]
dead to me but yeah forgive the guy so
you don't carry this anger around that
that's what I would do but don't let
that guy back in you know he did it once
he's gonna do it he's gonna do it again
alright frog in the scorpion can't help
it's Who I am
alright hey Bill I'm Alex and I never
thought I'd be the I never thought I'd
be the guy with the high school
sweetheart here I sit though having only
[ __ ] three women over the past 21
years and feeling pretty decent about it
I started off I still wait let me read
that again I'm Alex and I never thought
I'd be the guy with the high school
sweetheart here I sit though having only
[ __ ] three women over the past 21
years and feeling pretty decent about it
I gotta admit though you know you saved
yourself a lot of pain I missed out on a
lot of fun though
anyways I started dating
Biff I guess he's given a fake name when
I was 18 and ended up taking her
virginity three years later we are still
[ __ ] oh we over 21 years you just
mean you're 21 years old
I thought twenty-one years since you
started [ __ ] no all right only [ __ ]
three women over the last 21 years that
was really weird it worded in a weird
way were you supposed to get [ __ ] when
you were five you doing all right you're
a little behind but you know you're not
gonna get sent down to the minors if you
have one of those who was a relationship
you don't cheat that's a good thing all
right three years later we are still
[ __ ] and it's all very dope but I
worry about the amount of dicks she is
experienced I mean I'm sure we'll be
broken up and hating each other at some
point in the near future
but what if this awesome relationship
continues until my pubes are withered
and I can't get it up basically we're in
college I think we should both be having
more moments that fill us with
self-loathing
am i keeping her from a healthy number
of big minority [ __ ] jammed in her hole
where the hell did that come from should
I just be happy that this girl is
willing to [ __ ] me on a regular basis I
don't know bill any advice would be
appreciated appreciate it Alex stop
putting the fact that you want to [ __ ]
other people on your girlfriend that's
what I think you're doing either that
are you're unbelievably insecure about
the size of your own dick and that she
wants to go bang somebody else I have no
idea you got to figure out what it is
all right if you want to go bang a bunch
of other women you got to let this one
go you got to let this one go all right
if you're [ __ ] insecure about
something else you're just gonna mind
[ __ ] yourself right out of this
relationship all right if she's gonna
break up with you let her make that
decision don't don't make it for her by
being of overbearing Psychopaths that's
what I would say all right so there you
go good luck to you all right
overrated underrated underrated
underrated not biting the hand that
feeds you
don't [ __ ] this the girl who works at
Subway and then not call her back when
her store location is closest to your
job now you got to drive 15 minutes out
of your way to get lunch just because
you didn't like the way your vagina
looked ah dude you know what this is
what you do go back to that subway just
come in there with a big smile on your
face look just because some girl [ __ ]
you doesn't mean you owe her a phone
call afterwards you don't all you're
doing is giving her false hope you rip
the band-aid off all I wanted to do was
bang you that's what we did and that's
it all right
I don't understand why you have to like
let him down easily you know I love I
just I just love how women act like sex
doesn't feel good for them to you know I
let you have sex with me no you had sex
with me
feels good to both of us I made you feel
good you made me feel good all right why
do you still gotta get some more I just
don't [ __ ] understand that well it's
all how you play it off look you should
have gone in there now it's good it's
gonna be a little weird cuz you haven't
been in there for a while what you
should have done you got it what you got
to do you banging the night before
alright and the very next day you walk
in there big smile eh are you doing let
me get a [ __ ] something on us
something with us something and let me
get some lettuce and tomato you know
what are you doing tonight I'm hanging
out with the guys we're gonna watch
gonna watch a game what are you doing oh
that's cool
see see you wanna like hang out again
sometime I don't know hey I had a good
time you know we'll just whatever just
be like look you know I'm in this point
in my life you know I'm not looking for
a girlfriend and they'll try to be
[ __ ] douchey to you but you just kill
it I'm just being honest with you you
know I don't want to hurt you I had a
great time with you last night
a great time you know I'm not one of
these guys who walks around town saying
anything we had a fun time you just
leave how do you get mad at that
you know stop acting like I raped you
[Laughter]
know that [ __ ] that I wish I knew when I
was younger that how much women
appreciate that sort of honesty you know
any time you're on a [ __ ] date and
they did where is this going nowhere I'm
just having a good time you know just
have a good time with me all right this
is not gonna develop into a relationship
that's what I feel right now I just feel
this isn't gonna develop into
relationship but I'm really physically
attracted to you all right and I'm
telling you you can open the door to
them starting to think well here's a guy
that I can do all this nasty [ __ ] that I
want to try but I'm worried that I'm
gonna be judged if this guy actually
doesn't have feelings for me this is a
there you go right there
treat me like the fuckstick that I the
[ __ ] is wrong with me all right that's
the podcast for this week everybody um
hey let me let me I'm back out on the
road my little vacation is over and I'm
tell you right now my stand-up vacation
is over and it couldn't [ __ ] happen
soon enough because as you notice this
podcast you know starting to taper off
haven't been on stage you know this is
the calm before the storm now I got a
whole bunch of dates coming up and I
wanted to you know I just wanted to
chill out before I [ __ ] build up
right before I do my special and by the
way tickets are on sale for my next
spits stand-up special if you guys
wanted to go to a taping of one of my
specials I'm going to be in Washington
DC at the Lincoln Theater on March 3rd
if you go to Bill burr com
click on shows it's the last one we have
listed down there if you can't make it
to that one I got a whole bunch of other
things this weekend around the country
I'm gonna be at the House of Blues in
Houston Texas on January 20th
January 21st first I'll be at the
Paramount Theater in Austin Texas and
then I do my read all right February 7th
I'm gonna be in Charlotte north
Karolina how funny is this I just
realized it's Black History Month and
I'm doing the redneck tour these [ __ ]
people are gonna be extra angry and
drunk why do they get a whole month
[ __ ] you you freckle-faced [ __ ]
comedy zone Charlotte North Carolina
February 7th big shout out to Ric Flair
Charlotte North Carolina if you're there
please come out
funniest [ __ ] ever best guy I
ever saw in the mic February 8th the
stardome comedy club in Alabama and then
I'm gonna be at the Buckhead Theatre in
Hotlanta Atlanta Georgia and then I got
some gigs in New Jersey I'm doing the
Fox Theatre in Connecticut Westbury New
York a lot of East Coast [ __ ] that's
what I got going on so please come on
out to a show I got my new DVD with me
preparing to make my next DVD oh my god
you know what I forgot to tell you guys
this is LA I'll tell you a story this
last thing I'm gonna tell you I did you
know I've been playing pick-up hockey
you know once a week out here in
California and uh it's been [ __ ]
great I finally bought a new pair of
skates
you know [ __ ] phenomenal told you my
last pair I bought 1985 Bauer Panthers
and then I bought a new pair of Bauer's
what's that 27 years [ __ ] later I
feel like I'm out there skating in my
socks it's like I'm wearing slippers
it's unbelievable
so anyways one of the guys long story
one of the guys knows a guy who knows a
guy who knows a guy who [ __ ] works
for the LA Kings don't ask me how but we
got to play a pickup game at the Staples
Center are you jealous
well you should be dude it was like
skating on the [ __ ] moon
it's the only way to describe it so
smoothest [ __ ] ice it was like they
had a gravity knob and they turned it
down a good like 15 [ __ ] percent I
mean I sucked but I saw guys who
unbelievable stickhandling and they got
on and on that ice and the puck was was
sliding so smoothly they had they even
had to adjust to that did I score a goal
no I didn't I didn't screw even with
blowing the [ __ ]
horn when you scored they had refs was
[ __ ] awesome
was awesome and I actually made one play
on defense and the goalie said nice play
defense and it filled me up like I was a
[ __ ] eight-year-old I swear to God
I'm still mentally a child it was
[ __ ] awesome one of the greatest
things I ever got to do so uh so anyways
people this is the life you can leap if
you don't get married and you don't have
kids I'm telling you if you can do [ __ ]
like that just [ __ ] with you you know
what you can do all of that you can do
all of it you can have it all you know
you can [ __ ] have it all you can bang
the chick it's subway and you can come
in there the next day and get a goddamn
Italian BMT whatever the [ __ ] they call
it and you don't have to bang her again
and you can be [ __ ] cool if you just
walk in there and you just be cool yeah
I had a great [ __ ] time all right
not too much male 1 that all right
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll talk to you next week
Oh NFL predictions next week ah
Patriots Ravens ah Jesus I have no
[ __ ] idea
I think I'm hoping the Patriots are
gonna win ugly and by win ugly I mean
we're gonna score a hard 23 points and
we're gonna win like 23 21 nail-biter
right down to the [ __ ] end our
defense really has to [ __ ] step it up
and I'm hoping that Edie Reed I never
wish injury on anybody but I was when he
came down awkwardly in the end zone I
definitely was not upset I didn't wish
it on him
I was excited good maybe he'll be a
little slower because they they the
[ __ ] Ravens are no joke they're just
no joke
and I love how little amount of time
they've been in this league yet that the
sound are they a fanbase maybe because
it's old cult fans but I don't know that
those fans have their [ __ ] together
those are real [ __ ] fans and that's a
badass franchise even like that logo
that looks like some sort of old-school
family crest
like they conquered some [ __ ] I don't
know storm some castles or some [ __ ]
it's gonna be a rough [ __ ] game I
have no idea
Giants 49ers I think the difference is
gonna be quarterback and I got to give
the nod to Eli over Alex Smith but I
can't underestimate Jim Harbaugh and how
[ __ ] amped up he gets his team it's
gonna be you know what [ __ ] this I'm
gonna pit I'm picking the 49ers I'm
picking the 49ers wait where is that
game that's gonna be in San Francisco
I'm picking the 49ers I just think that
they they that's like a that was like a
dormant volcano out there their fan base
and now all of a sudden that Joe Montana
Steve Young vibe is back and I think
Harbaugh is just a [ __ ] great coach
they got an unbelievable defense [ __ ] it
my gut says 49ers although I think Eli
is the goddamn man he likes the [ __ ]
man he finally got his do when he
deserves it so that's it so I alligator
arm picked the 49ers and because my I
gotta go with the Patriots win an ugly
23:20 hope it happens that's it that's
the podcast for this week I hope you
guys all have a good week go [ __ ]
yourself
you